I always start my day by drinking two
cups of water on an empty stomach just a
couple of days ago I was told that I
have a photo shoot arranged for a
magazine to me a healthy smell is
extremely important as it can leave a
long lasting first good impression so
I've always been using the Colgate optic
white products to give me whiter teeth I
especially love their new instant white
variant which uses the blue light
technology that reflects blue light from
your teeth to create an instantly whiter
smile I can see the difference right
after the first brush fresh breath write
a small check do you know someone who
would wear her workout clothes to bed
yep I'm the kind of person obviously not
with a sports bra on on a busy day like
this it gives me no excuse to fit in a
quick 20 minute bodyweight workout and I
always feel amazing after a workout
session ladies the prettiest thing you
can wear is your smile so every morning
while getting ready
remember to smile to yourself smiling
it's also contagious and you might just
lift someone's day with your smile
even if I were in a rush I will never
leave home without having my breakfast
so I've made my breakfast the night
before
overnight oatmeal this breakfast is
filling quick to put together and very
easy to be eaten when I'm driving to
work I like to listen to
self-development audiobooks it serves as
a daily reminder of my purpose goals and
to get my day started off on the right
foot what do you listen to in the
morning
so that's a wrap I'm going to head for
some lunch right now
bye guys so I want to encourage you to
take a little bit of effort to plan your
morning the night before and I can
assure you you will have a stress-free
and productive morning to celebrate my
birthday this month they kill gate optic
white instant white team wants to
inspire each and every one of you to put
on a whiter and brighter smile and to
give you the confidence you need to have
an amazing day ahead so this toothpaste
is new in the market and they want you
guys to be the first to try out they are
giving away 10 goodie bags for those of
you who are living in Malaysia and
Singapore to win this huge giveaway it
is really simple all you have to do is
leave your comments below let me know
what puts a smile on your face hashtag a
brighter smile and the country you're
from so I will be announcing the winners
by the end of September so be sure to
leave your comment and share this
giveaway with your friends don't forget
to like this video share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel for new
weekly videos keep smiling
you